♪ ♪
>> Laura: JOIN ME NOW IS
HARRIET HAGEMAN, THE WYOMING
CONGRESSIONAL CANDIDATE WHO JUST
DEFEATED LIZ CHENEY.
HARRIET, FIRST OF ALL,
CONGRATULATIONS.
I REMEMBER TALKING TO YOU BEFORE
YOU DECIDED YOU WERE GOING TO
THROW YOUR HAT IN THE RING FOR
REAL, AND NOW, YOU KNOW, YOU'VE
GOT IT, GIRL, YOU'RE GOING TO BE
THE NOMINEE FOR THE PARTY AND I
CAN'T IMAGINE YOU WON'T BE THE
NEXT CONGRESSWOMAN FROM THE
GREAT STATE OF WYOMING.
>> WELL, THANK YOU, LAURA, IT'S
WONDERFUL TO BE BACK WITH YOU.
WE STARTED THIS YEAR AGO OR
ABOUT 11 MONTHS AGO AND HERE WE
ARE WITH ALL OF THE HARD WORK
AND THE SUPPORT OF THE GREAT
PEOPLE ACROSS THE STATE OF
WYOMING AND ALL OF OUR
VOLUNTEERS AND SUPPORTERS.
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO SUCCEED.
>> Laura: DID LIZ CHENEY CALL
YOU AND CONGRATULATE YOU?
HOW WAS THE TONE OF THE
CONVERSATION?
>> I HAVEN'T HAD AN OPPORTUNITY
TO VISIT WITH HER.
WE HAVE BEEN KIND OF WRAPPED UP
IN ALL OF THE STUFF ASSOCIATED
WITH WHAT'S GOING ON DOWNSTAIRS
WITHOUT A WATCH PARTY, AS YOU
CAN IMAGINE.
WE HAVE SEVERAL HUNDRED PEOPLE
DOWNSTAIRS READY TO CELEBRATE,
WHO HAVE BEEN CELEBRATING, AND
SO I HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO EVEN
LOOK AT MY PHONE, SO I DON'T
KNOW IF SHE'S CALLED OR NOT.
SO I DON'T REALLY HAVE ANYTHING
TO REPORT ON THAT.
>> Laura: THAT'S INTERESTING.
DID YOU HAPPEN TO HEAR THAT PART
OF HER SPEECH WAS A CONTINUED
VOW, HARRIET, TO MAKE SURE
DONALD TRUMP NEVER STEPPED FOOT
IN THE WHITE HOUSE AFTER WHAT
HAPPENED ON JANUARY 6TH, WHICH
WAS -- I GUESS NOT SURPRISING
THAT SHE SAID THAT, BUT YOUR
REACTION TONIGHT?
>> AGAIN, I HAVE NOT HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO EVEN SEE OR HEAR
WHAT SHE HAD TO SAY, BECAUSE
I'VE BEEN KIND OF FOCUSED ON
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE.
IT DOESN'T SURPRISE ME THAT SHE
WOULD REVERT TO THOSE SAME OLD
TALKING POINTS, BECAUSE THAT'S
REALLY IN LARGE PART WHAT GOT
HER DEFEATED.
SHE IS NOT FOCUSING ON WYOMING,
SHE'S NOT FOCUSING ON OUR
ISSUES.
SHE IS STILL FOCUSING ON AN
OBSESSION ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND THE CITIZENS OF WYOMING, THE
VOTERS OF WYOMING SENT A VERY
LOUD MESSAGE TONIGHT.
WE HAVE SPOKEN.
AND THAT IS NOT WHAT WE ARE
INTERESTED IN IN TERMS OF OUR
LOAN CONGRESSIONAL
REPRESENTATIVE.
WYOMING IS ENTITLED TO HAVE A
REPRESENTATIVE THAT REPRESENTS
OUR INTERESTS, LISTENS TO US,
ADDRESSES OUR ISSUES.
THAT ISN'T LIZ CHENEY AND THE
FACT THAT THAT'S WHERE SHE WENT
BACK TO WITH HER SPEECH TONIGHT
I THINK DEMONSTRATES THAT SHE
REALLY IS LISTENING TO WYOMING
NOW, SHE HASN'T FOR QUITE SOME
TIME, AND THAT'S WHY WE NEEDED
TO REPLACE HER.
WE NEED TO HAVE A REPRESENTATIVE
IN WYOMING WHO LISTENS TO US.
>> Laura: AND, HARRIET, WHAT I
WAS LUCKY ENOUGH TO SPEND QUITE
A BIT OF TIME IN WYOMING IN
JULY, THE THINGS THAT I HEARD
MOST OFTEN FROM FOLKS THERE WERE
INABILITY TO GET WORKERS, THE
COST OF FUEL, AND THE COST OF
JUST BASIC LIVING.
RENT, AND FOOD.
NO ONE WAS FOCUSING ON TRUMP.
I DON'T THINK ANYONE I TALKED
TO, THAT WASN'T TOP OF MIND.
>> NO.
INFLATION, ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION,
AND PROTECTION OF OUR ENERGY
JOBS ARE THE ISSUES THAT ARE THE
MOST IMPORTANT TO WYOMING.
AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
WE ACTUALLY EXPECT OUR
REPRESENTATIVES WERE PRESENT ARE
INTERESTS.
THAT'S WHAT I'VE HEARD SO MUCH
ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
IF SO I'M EXCITED, THANK YOU FOR
HAVING US.
IT'S A WONDERFUL EVENING.
>> Laura: HARRIET,
CONGRATULATIONS, WE CAN'T WAIT
TO